le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
l'agriculture est à la réunion un
secteur porteur créateurs de richesses
et d'emplois
les agriculteurs contribuent aussi à
aménager le territoire a façonné nos
beaux paysages par ailleurs ils
produisent des produits sains bons pour
la santé
mais qui sont trop souvent encore
concurrencés par des importations à
moindre coût
alors comment aider les agriculteurs et
faire connaître leurs produits
comment faire découvrir aux citadins les
richesses de la production locale on en
parle maintenant dans lien social
le quartier du bas de la rivière à saint
denis était autrefois un lieu à vocation
industrielle et agricole
il a activement participé au
développement du chef lieu de la réunion
très actif ce quartier a été fortement
peuplées et très urbanisées
mais les fermetures successives des
usines ont considérablement réduit la
fréquentation du quartier presque laissé
à l'abandon
le conseil général a souhaité redonner
vie au bas de la rivière et en faire un
éco quartier pilote
expérience qui pourrait ensuite être
développée sur d'autres communes
après des aménagements urbains et la
renaissance du collège de l'est il
s'agit maintenant de relancer une vie
sociale dans ce lieu chargé d'histoire
le conseil général a donc cherché des
solutions pour permettre aux différentes
populations de se retrouver d'échanger
de partager
c'est de cette conviction que sont nées
les marchés pays qui ont lieu tous les
deuxièmes mercredis du mois à l'espace
rédelé
l'objectif est d'apporter du soutien aux
agriculteurs réunionnais dont certains
exerçant à saint denis en leur offrant
plus de points de vente et permettre aux
habitants du quartier de redécouvrir les
produits péi de qualité
patrick est agriculteur depuis 25 ans il
connaît bien les difficultés que
rencontre le monde agricole en général
et trouve que le marché pays est une
belle idée qui lui apporte un soutien
financier mais aussi social
la passerelle vol les marchés forains
nombre de faces el-oued et fois c'est
pas pareil être concurrents pour épauler
les produits très difficile et
l'imaginaire je trouve ça très très
intéressant au niveau
contact avec les gens au niveau lavande
même au niveau 1 au niveau
financièrement pour le
revenu c'est un plus
j'ai présenté le
battle et légumes est très très ancien
il découvre des choses mais aussi on
découvre notre
connaissance a discuté un peu
pour voir on a donné nos
nos idées aussi j'ai dit aux
responsables que un truc il faut pas
arrêter par été signé
avec les artisans
comme patrick beaucoup d'agriculteurs
ont besoin de soutien l'aspect financier
n'est pas la seule raison d'aider le
monde agricole ce sont des métiers très
difficile et la reconnaissance n'est pas
forcément au rendez-vous
grâce au marché pays les agriculteurs
présents sur les stands peuvent partager
l'amour de leur métier avec les clients
ils peuvent parler avec passion de leurs
produits au grand bonheur des acheteurs
c'est une équation parfaite car le
client y trouve non seulement des
produits frais mais à meilleur prix
car c'est une vente directe entre
l'agriculteur et le consommateur
des produits à la réunion sont bons de
bonne qualité avec même des produits bio
et nous avons beaucoup accompagner les
agriculteurs qui ont fait des efforts
considérables à la règle on mange bien
en produit bien mais il faut que le
consommateur lui-même pigalle et quand
on met en place et marché pays on évite
les intermédiaires du producteur au
consommateur c'est de la vente directe
ce qui permet également d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des familles
réunionnaises tout en soutenant la
production locale et en soutenant le bon
manger créole avec les produits frais
chaque 2e
autrefois surnommé le grenier de saint
denis le quartier du bas de la rivière
est en train de renouer avec le
mieux-vivre
écoquartier en cours il revit grâce à
des animations économique et social le
marché pays est un formidable moyen de
relier les gens entre eux les
populations se retrouvent échange
partage et elle redécouvre des produits
qui ont fait la réunion tout cela en
aidant les agriculteurs et en proposant
des produits à meilleur prix au
consommateur le marché pays est un
exemple à suivre car il prouve que la
solidarité apporte des solutions à tous
les acteurs d'un même dispositif
pour répondre à la demande des
consommateurs le conseil général a
décidé de changer les dates des marchés
pays au lieu dès mercredi le marché pays
se tiendra désormais à partir du mois de
septembre
les deuxièmes samedis toujours à
l'espace régler au bas de la rivière le
conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais